(playful surfing music)
- We're trying on vintage men's swimsuits.
- I've never tried a
vintage bathing suit before,
so I'm a little nervous.
- I'm sure they're gonna show more crotch.
- This makes me feel like
my father's going to sell me
for three goats.
- This is a skirt.
- A sweater-type material.
- I don't know how to
tell what's the front.
- Hello.
- I'm very, very uncomfortable right now.
- It's really itchy.
- The groin area is nice.
- Kind of just a dress
with shorts underneath.
- What is this giant,
unpleasant feeling diaper
you've give me?
- I don't know if these
would bode well in the water.
- I'm glad that it has this netting stuff,
because this wool would be
really itchy on your junk.
(laughing)
- What up?
- This is man diaper.
- It's itchy, but in a good way.
- I feel like a really lame superhero.
- Bam, greenies.
- Even shorter than the last ones.
- Green pants, red beard:
I feel like a leprechaun
superhero right now.
- I feel like Robin Hood on the weekend,
when he wants to just
like chill with homeboys.
- It feels like more of a swim fabric.
- I think these are supposed
to probably go higher,
like high-waisted, but
that's not going on.
- This is a men's?
- Oh, it's a one piece.
- Pretty sure it's backwards.
- Hello, ladies.
And gentlemen.
- You know, it's a little tight.
This one's like just tall
enough to cover the nip.
This is like Great
Grandma Tilda's swimsuit.
- I'm into vintage clothes,
but apparently not swimsuits.
- Not my thing.
- Not a big fan,
but my grandfather and great grandfather,
hooray to you guys for getting out there
and showing it to the world.